we are one day away from the NFL trade
deadline we are one day removed from a
great day in the NFL and I am currently
in the present sitting with the man the
myth the legend the hardest-working man
in show business Mike Tirico I'm just
kidding hey Chris Sims hello how are you
how are you well I was just looking over
our bets from the weekend oh yeah pretty
well today yeah just a little bet update
for everybody out there if the bills
lose tonight yes Chris Sims goes
Ivano and guaranteed to lose that's a
guarantee then I'm guaranteed to go 5
and out if the bills lose tonight the
bills lose by 14 or more like Tom
Brady's gonna have liked to have that
another human crawl out of his ass
tonight for them to lose like during the
game like even if it had a hognose
Brady's if the rate if the Patriots win
by 14 or more and you're listening to
this on Tuesday morning so you already
know if I won or lost
I will go three and one left Cole ox Oh
also they went by 14 or more Sims you
will venture forth into the positive in
Sims and left go betting is that right
you will have gone from minus 610 to
plus 90 if the Patriots win by 14
gosh can they possibly not win by 14 it
just feels so it feels so right it feels
wrong I don't even want to talk about it
cuz I know that tomorrow they're gonna
be like oh and then like cordarrelle
Patterson fumbled that kick return that
went for a touchdown and Brady got
surprised by Jung [ __ ] hey Josh Gordon
didn't play Josh Gordon just decided to
give the ball to another other team
today vs white ran for a touchdown
you're on Sunday Night Football another
sterling experience with you on the
screen sterling yeah thank you yeah it's
good I mean it's always great it's hard
to quantify you're in pay I know that I
know I know got a little kid genius in
on the national stage yep and that game
went uh not how we expected at all
definitely not but that's that you came
in today and I talked about Maine you
know what the Ravens didn't do this they
could have won that game and if they
didn't do this and if the Minnesota
destroyed that game and Cleveland had a
chance against Pittsburgh and you go
left go when are you gonna realize that
the difference between the best team in
the NFL in the worst
see the NFL is what four snaps I mean it
were play that's how close it is this
day so would you say it's the best team
in the NFL right now the Rams or the
Chiefs I will go the Rams so the Rams
and who's the worst team in the NFL oh
gosh Raiders god I mean am I gonna
really have to let's say that though
let's just say Raiders readers are one
of the Titans or one of the Bay Area
teens Raiders or Niners I mean or Giants
or Giants but yeah I guess like you know
if if two balls bounce their way yeah no
no it's crazy it's the NFL it's not
college football it is so close and it's
something that I have conversations with
with Coach friends all the time
especially the older coaches like there
they are more hell-bent on that than
ever because well just the fact that you
know 20 years ago there was more
separation between teams you know what I
mean right and all information was
proprietary and now you gotta rip that
off yeah and then now yeah I think that
especially the coaches that have been
around for a while they're just amazed
with how close the games are and how it
really does come down to yeah how it
really does come down to three or four
plays like you're saying hey I totally
feel you like what you're saying with
the Ravens game you know the Ravens
they're here they're gonna do this Oh
Alex Collins fumble damn that changed
the pace of the game yes or the Vikings
are controlling the whole first habits
1310 and they're driving and the inland
fumbles and the game's never the same
feelin fumbles to give them like a
double-digit lead yeah it sets up the
Saints to score and then you start the
second half and the Vikings go for it on
fourth down on their own 45 and their
defense came over and great what was the
point I don't understand I don't know so
yeah but like the Ravens game
Lamar misses a wide open wide receiver
on the third and one Carolina two plays
later touchdown 7-7 then Alex Collins
fumbles on his own 12 era Linus scores
few plays later 14-7 second quarter
Carolina drives 99 yards ball gets
deflected in the end zone
caught by McCaffrey yeah 21 7 and right
there you're like me and three of those
plays like even the DJ more 30-yard run
he fumbled fresh too
could have been like a disaster I'd
pitch by cam and just the balances right
- exactly right do you want to start
there with that game right there and
then okay fine and Josh came up with a
screw you then one thing self scouting
is we are at the time of the year where
the cream of the crop has presented
themselves I told you I did the four
teams that we always talk about it I got
them still under this jacket but it is
Rams Chiefs Patriots Saints Saints went
out there they got the win it was a
pretty that's a huge win for seeding in
the NFC and all that but we've noticed
this doing a show now together for three
four years is that it can get a little
repetitive talking about the same team
that's right
so self Scout to all the Rams fans out
there and and and all the guys are like
why are you talking about your team we
will talk about your team we do need to
talk about the Rams more like last last
week the Rams beat up on the Niners and
we didn't talk about it at all well yeah
okay you're right so it's just about
kind of why there are people complaining
about it that we didn't do it of course
I got it I understand it yeah they
looked for us to talk about their teams
and I get it yeah
almost as much as I look for you to show
up in Atlanta the week before the Super
Bowl
a little birdie Stella leaves a little
birdie in my ear that apparently
Bleacher Report's rented out a bar right
in the middle of the action like right
in the middle of that bar Sims and left
go tequila shots and NFL players one
person that's gonna have time to go
wherever he wants on any day of the week
huge accident no Hugh Jackson has been
fired surprised Todd Haley also fired
I was surprising Liberty kitchens
filling in yeah I was really hoping that
Wylie the offensive line coach was gonna
get a chance to in a row the season's
over let that man call plays yeah see
your gut raised when you talk apparently
they were undecided about who to let go
apparently when it went to the owner and
the GM dorcy dorcy wanted Hugh gone and
the owner didn't want Hugh gone and
eventually they got rid of Hugh
what is your take on all this just just
overall the day of we're recording this
3:30 on a Monday yeah I am surprised I
guess I would say just the fact that it
happened this week I didn't think it
would happen I thought really maybe it
would be a bi-week thing in two weeks I
mean either way I think you and I both
knew like this was coming whether it was
by week or end of the season either way
it was going it was definitely I mean
John Dorsey Hugh Jackson's not his guy
he was gonna find somebody after the
season that is his guy and he's still
going to do that interesting about the
Hugh Jackson thing I mean I had hugest
hasn't hailed himself right I don't
really know what to say it's always a
little place blame or I don't know just
so there's a way about him even in his
press conferences that just don't they
rub me the wrong way and they host the
clip on Simpson left go when in the
first episode of hard knocks
Todd Haley's going we lack toughness on
this team and I've been taught Haley in
that situation I've been the guy in the
meeting go and look I'm gonna speak for
the 15 people here that are afraid to
speak these guys are soft they need to
be harder we need it for the season and
Hugh came out and said listen I I know
what it's like to be in your seat but
this is my seat and I get to do whatever
I want is on the head coach yeah and I I
remember that we came back and I was
like that's awful yeah like I would
never want to work for the right right
Todd Haley's been to the playoffs as a
head coach you you have known what do
you think about Todd Haley getting fired
too well I mean that's the part I think
when I first heard that and then added
to your Jimmy Haslam wanted Hugh to stay
you know he would obviously endeared
himself the Jimmy hasn't that's the only
way you can survive a one in 31 start in
the NFL you obviously if the owner likes
you okay
and it sounded like the owner was
willing to ride it out for the year but
we like someone giving him all the
information like I bet you Hugh would
talk to Jimmy and tell him what was
going exactly fill them in because a lot
of these owners want to be a part of the
coaching yes and it's either you the
head coach or the GM who's endearing
themselves to the owner and it sounded
like you won that that battle last year
when the Todd Haley is not gonna endear
him
so anybody howdy Abel he's a football
coach Harley was wants to draw plays he
wants to tell you to be tougher and do
things and then he wants to go drink a
beer I mean that's what that's the way
Todd Haley is there's nothing more to
him I like Todd Haley always have some
little offense I don't know I really
don't know what to tell you there I mean
they just are gonna move on and they're
gonna start restructuring their
organization and they're gonna look to
build their team for next year not that
they're gonna give up on this year but
interim coach Greg Williams yeah the guy
to navigate them through this dark and
stormy night
he's got great people skills Pires he
like Greg Williams I mean he's full of
energy he can motivate there's all
there's that aspect of it but I really
don't know and that's something that I'm
a week after Myles Garrett questioned
his defense two days after days yes I
was Garrett questioned his defensive
game yeah yeah that's okay
and you know I like the way Myles handle
that too just like we have open dialogue
he needs to hear this we played good on
this scheme week one against them why
did we change it all up for this game
rap sheet reporting from what I hear big
mayfield is not exactly gonna miss huge
it okay well yeah okay okay I was you
thought you were about to say Todd Haley
I thought maybe there's another aspect
of somebody not liking Todd Haley um but
no I feel like Hugh on his way out was
like listen I've been fighting with Todd
just please don't name him the
replacement after me if I can get one
request let him go I mean I guess yeah
listen to you I don't know what to say
he just I don't think he rubs a lot of
the players the right way I think they
see through Hugh I'll go always go back
at your feet away the eight and eight
year when he was the Oakland Raiders and
they lost the last game of the year when
they traded for Carson Palmer that year
right they got done and he placed the
whole blame on the players and that
always stuck with me him the pliers I'm
so mad at my pliers they let up let me
down what like what who says that after
a crushing week 17 loss or you missed
the playoffs like take some
accountability nobody wants to hear that
crap and that's what got his ass run out
of
and him with these little pissing
moaning matches that he went through the
last few weeks with the coaching staff
and the media you know don't come after
the game yesterday and act like oh you
guys made this a story about Todd Haley
no you did you you did I don't know what
else just saying you said something
about the offense and that you might
have to get involved in the pike hauling
when you're the head coach of one of the
32 NFL teams and you make a statement
like that it becomes a story that's so
annoying to me about there's a few head
coaches in football right now that make
those comments and they're like oh you
guys are making a story of this yeah we
are sorry you know Jon Gruden when you
say Amari Cooper is open and Derek Carr
didn't throw to him that's a story it
doesn't we don't just go oh oh
Jon that's good one we'll move on let's
I don't get that what we have witnessed
is not the worst coach of all time
that's not what we've witnessed the only
coach were the worst winning percentage
than him was Bert Bell of the
Philadelphia Eagles and you know why
Bert Bell lasted so long Chris Sims how
long did he last longer than you because
he was also the owner of the Eagles
that's awesome so the only guy with a
worse winning percentage than Hugh
Jackson was a guy that owned his own
team and wanted to keep coaching we did
not witness the worst coaching
performance what we witnessed was one of
the greatest coaching performances of
our lifetime so often we hear about
these coordinators they get the head
coaching job and we sit there we go
sure he's got the schematics but does
they have the people skills sometimes
they're a good people person go how
where's the X's and O's Hugh had none of
that
and was able to maintain his job for
longer than many other coaches ever get
a chance can you imagine being so good
in the office that you go one in 31 and
there's not even talk of you being fired
I know it's that son could you imagine
going 1 in 15 coming out in from the
press conference and going there's no
way we're that bad that
next year and if we are I'll jump into
Lake Erie and you go Owen 16 the next
year and we're laughing and jumping in
the water with you do you know how good
of a coach you have to be to let all
that stuff ride it's incredible
if Bill Belichick lost 1069 games in a
row he would still have a better winning
percentage than Hugh Jackson he has to
lose 1,070 football games in a row that
is nearly 67 seasons in a row to match
that winning percentage and he wasn't
fired we're sitting here today surprised
that Hugh Jackson is fired and I said
how can a man possess these qualities
that allows him to escape the wrath I'm
impressed
it's incredible yeah I looked up his
birthday October 22nd a Libra which is a
little bit tough because it means it was
a birthday a week ago yeah you knew all
shares that birthday another politician
con-artist absolutely not yeah wouldn't
even do that because if you're a con
artist
it all comes crumbling down for Hugh
it's a way of life shaggy and what
Shaggy's most famous song Chris Simms
hold on it wasn't me it wasn't you
thought I lost all the way where did you
do this research it wasn't me where did
we saw it on Owen 16 it wasn't it this
is my iPod Haley is a problem it wasn't
me
you got a firearm gotta stop him it
wasn't me Hugh Jackson is the shaggy of
the NFL and we didn't appreciate shaggy
until it was too late I need you to
appreciate what Hugh Jackson just did to
us he went 336 and won and we're sitting
here today shocked that he was fired now
Bravo yeah Bravo
hey that is you are the greatest left Co
bleacher report you need to put left go
to work more because he's obviously got
way too much freedom
his hand to be looking up [ __ ] like that
that he just came out with their the
really scary thing is how quickly I turn
it around is how quickly I can go okay
let's just reverse engineer [ __ ]
but Hugh Jackson I mean the funny thing
is is Hugh Jackson getting fired is
vindication for everybody at their jobs
who has another employee that doesn't do
good work always lies comes into work
late
puts projects on their desk instead of
their own take summer fridays in the
winter and doesn't work hard and never
gets called out for it that's huge
accident is vindication for all of the
employees that go why do i get treated
on a different level than this person
yeah no offense oh yeah that's a good
apology yes no no offense taken left go
thank you who should the Browns be
looking for I mean obviously the
connections to Lincoln Riley at Oklahoma
he's already having to answer I don't
have the interest in the NFL just ya
know he was the head coach for Baker
okay so what type of guy it doesn't
matter I don't know it's a do only
enough you're the staunch yeah but like
when you look at this Browns team do you
want them to have a name that we've
known before do you want them to get a
young wunderkind that can make it all
happen you don't want to talk about it
well I I'm so over the brown subject
like we're we talk about them newswise
like when you send me the text like all
I want you to break down the Browns
offense or may I say who the [ __ ] cares
about the Browns it's over get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
all the good games on the list yesterday
and you sent me watch the Browns offense
versus stealing the number five option
gosh damn boy because the reason I want
to know is I do think they need somebody
proven I will say that they need to go
down that list somewhere they do we've
learned well thank you I've learned a
left go trick but no I think it would
have to be somebody like that somebody
that's come from winning before that can
install that you know what do I want to
say winning culture in that locker room
I guess that would be the biggest thing
I would look for and I would say that if
it
doesn't happen and doesn't work out
always remember a team is only as good
as their owner have you made me guess
like I've told you before if I had a go
and just the way the season setting up
right now oh if if you and me look and
you know me I like to connect dots super
early Sims prognostication Gruber 29 Bay
Packers don't go to the playoffs Mike
McCarthy is the guy I would say I could
see that happening in Cleveland because
exactly those are the things I always
look at first to go he looked good for
them
Yeah right and he's tough and I got we
always say I get on Mike McCarthy a lot
as the offensive play car I like him as
a head coach his team's play hard they
play physical he manages situational
football pretty well but I just don't
like him to PyCon that's the only thing
I complained about him always just can
we infuse another idea up there in Green
Bay but that's where my mind goes to
first and then I go huh okay he was at
Kansas City before that is there
connections there and that's where you
know not to say that this guy's a head
coach material yet but and Eric be enemy
getting him in as an OC I don't know
things like that I can't and II read
lets him go but those are that's just
the way my brain works as soon as I hear
these type of things yeah where I think
one question that we get asked by a ton
of people is yeah who were the hot
coordinators that could end up being
head coaches right and I see other
people make lists but that's something I
don't want to put any more work on your
plate but going forward no I mean we can
get into that I just oh I got ya now
yeah not now right the other big news
from Monday afternoon is Ryan
Fitzpatrick is officially starting do
they make him the starter oh you didn't
notice I've been in in the lab you been
in a pad one more man I forget there so
what are you trying to get my damn label
off that's not bad I think you're right
Ryan Fitzpatrick I heard you in Lebanon
Fitzpatrick yeah I don't even know how
it was really a debate for everyone that
I heard saying well Jason late
after Jameis Winston and he's worried
about keeping his job okay
look like everyone can acknowledge
what's happening with Jameis Winston
right and Jason lights starting Jameis
over Ryan Fitzpatrick is not gonna keep
his job I go back to what you said you
had it you hit the nail on the head
right from the get-go really yeah you
did
left co-credit your opportunity to get
away from when you said that when the
Bears game a few weeks ago oh yeah you
stole that rabbit art today I did
because that's a great it was a great
that was the right way to look at it I'm
not saying I got me there but you said
that yeah right
like come on where were you being
benching him for the Bears the the Bears
ran four plays in the whole first half
and scored on the same four plays like
six different times and we're gonna
bench the quarterback against the Bears
who still have one of the better
defenses in all the football yeah and
Khalil Mack was healthy and all that
yeah that made no sense and you were
spot-on about that how can the team look
so bad with Sheamus and so much better
with Fitzpatrick now I will say I did
completely predict that that Jameis on
the road is when he just starts going
I'm gonna win this game when I sell when
they drove down the field the first ride
and threw it and the interception I
promise you I thought of you right away
is that up I said on the road is gonna
happen I was like cuz after the first
you throws I went okay James looks good
today yeah well Jameis always looks good
yeah but then he goes to guys on that
one guy I could fit it in and it's it's
crazy it is it's crazy he has no
limitation on you know but you're
watching thanks Patrick after throwing a
70 yard touchdown to Mike Evans driving
him down the field and then on a
two-point conversion juking a pass
rusher and throwing a laser in the
middle a two-point conversion
right he's the guy yeah I hear you I got
to go with him and same thing we look at
a lot of situations I think a
quarterback like I don't think you can
Dirk cutter look at your team
realistically after that performance ago
all we're gonna start Jameis again this
week like that's just that's not gonna
fly the locker rooms are like are we
trying to win yeah they're gonna
question the coach and I think this is
the right decision I would say - I heard
dark cutter after the game talking about
all the matchups his team it's
so hard to defend I mean it really is
with Winston with with Evans DeSean
Jackson Oh J Howard who was one of the
best tight end mismatches in the game
Humphreys is super solid yeah and then
Godwin yes and you still have Cameron
Breit if you want to do two tight end
set right
Payton barbers not bad Ronald Jones to
the second round pick and Fitzpatrick
just finds the open guys yeah where
Winston makes his own decision throws in
the defender is he gone off the team
next year I'll bring him back I I would
think so you know I told you I mean I
know before this all went down I'd have
a hard time I would have had a hard time
starting Jameson's than ever again I
think if I was the head coach or the
owner just after the offseason and the
uber incident and all that like you know
how many strikes do you get learn from
the Eli situation yeah if Ben McAdoo
benches Eli and you know that he's not
the guy don't reverse course right
you're probably gonna fire Dirk cutter
the same way that the Giants fired Ben
Mac mm-hmm
let that transition happen under a fired
coach's watch because then it's not on
the new coach to have to make a decision
and get at the press conference and take
all the flak and if they replace him
with a guy that doesn't turn out well
it's his bad decision now's the time to
get away from it
everything's coming to an end I said
this last week it's time to blow up the
Bucks it's time to just hit reset you've
got a lot of good pieces on the D line
you've got a lot of good past catchers
and weapons your old lines coming
together you put some money with a Lamar
pet you know you got some athletes at
linebacker if they can ever stay healthy
but you know quarterback secondary yeah
no it's just time to restart all right
coach GM it's just time to restart yeah
III agree with you there and I mean I
think that's what's what's going to
happen they need a regime change
probably there in Tampa definitely okay
and then I would also stay for Jameis
Winston that he needs a change of
scenery he's gonna get out of the state
of Florida that would be my first thing
just get out like he's gotta get I needs
a new look he needs a new attitude
he needs a jolt in his life in a little
place where he's not warm and co
see and everybody's in love with him
because he won the national championship
at Florida State it's weird that I'm
thinking about this but after the game
for Washington New York did you see the
video of Adrian Peterson talking to say
quantum Berkeley it was awesome well I
was I did not see it but it was as
though Adrian Peterson was miked up the
audio quality was so good right and he's
sitting there and he's going you're
special
you have everything look at you you're
like you're made to do this just grind
every day no days off be the best you
can be these are all things that if I
said to say quantum Berkeley he'd go
okay I've heard this a million times but
that hearing it from Adrian Peterson
you're going okay I'm gonna work hard
about it he said it during last week I
mean during the week leading up to the
game somebody asked him about say Kwan
and he said listen there's been some
good running backs have been drafted
early the last few years you know
Leonard fournette ZQ oh yeah but this
guy is cut from a different cloth like
he was telling you yes and he knows and
of course you see it I mean say Kwan
special there's and I think Jamis needs
that on a regular basis yeah because the
bad thing about having Ryan Fitzpatrick
is your backup is if he has success you
go I should be having double success
sure I'm double more athletic better
than him I can make all those throws and
then you get out there and then it's
almost like this doesn't make sense
yeah Jameis needs to sit behind somebody
Jameis needs to have a quarterback coach
or an offensive coordinator
that's super well-versed achievements
needs to become a student again yeah now
the question is is is he gonna retain it
is he gonna be able to process it and do
it because there's a reason he went
first pick in the jury yeah I don't I'm
not giving up on Jameson's career
certainly I'm not cuz there's talent
there and like we've always said for the
last two years and even the end of last
year when he was really phenomenal like
you turned the film on and Jameis is
good is really really good preseason
Jameis was one of the best quarterbacks
in football this preseason he was so
maybe there's just Jameis vs. bass yeah
there's something there and they're just
gonna have to find day yeah he needs to
go somewhere where there's a coach that
puts a poker in his ass daily where he's
not annoying
the king of the area and he has to earn
his stripes again to get back on the
field I doubt that Jameis will be traded
but everyone is warming us up for a
crazy trade deadline you're a big texter
of people that are in the know yeah I'm
seeing all these reports from Jay Glazer
and Rappaport and shefter saying this
could be one of the craziest trade
deadlines we've ever seen we've already
seen some stuff happened that I didn't
expect right what do you expect in the
next 24 hours because again we are
recording this 3:30 on Monday so by
tomorrow morning who the heck knows
what's gonna happen yeah I think the
interesting thing is first of all you
have teams like your Philadelphia Eagles
who are sitting on the edge of the
playoffs right now who I still think are
one of the better teams in the NFC I
really do I mean I would have you said
oh the Bears have to the Bears are
number three in the end of the Redskins
are number three right now I think the
Eagles are better than the Reds and the
Bears right I agree I'm not gonna say
they're better than Carolina even though
they outplayed Carolina in that football
game but Carolina has been Carolina's
outplayed just about everybody they've
played this year except for Philadelphia
really yeah you know Elena okay that
could go either way
early in the year when Atlanta was
totally healthy but you're saying that
there's a lot of teams that are really
good yes there are a few pieces of wire
too right and I guess I look at of
course I expect New England to make a
move I do at two positions I really
think I think they're gonna look to add
another receiver or that was glaze laser
said the Pats are looking for a stud
wide receiver
so they got Josh Gordon let me play
devil's advocate go ahead they have
Grunk they have Edelman James White is
practically a pass catcher out of the
backfield
I don't men in Hogan are not the same
players this year I think that's the
first thing I would say to that Edelman
is not as explosive as quick and maybe
he's still getting back from injury
maybe it's he's been cheating for a long
time I don't know what else to say Gronk
has been battling injury and I think we
know that like Josh Gordon's in the
trust tree right he's in the trust tree
dealing with a hamstring injury himself
tonight right
so I think they're looking at it going
dim there's Josh Gordon can we totally a
hundred percent trust him yet probably
not he's in the trust tree for Tom Brady
yes you know but when when Glazer says
stud wide receiver yeah paycheck
my mind went right to one thing right a
Larry Fitzgerald no Dale but no he's a
perfect thing but well I thought again I
connect dots where did josh mcdaniels
come from before this denver who did he
draft tameria's tell exactly right you
sicko he's put on the trade block right
so those are things I just think of
right away when I heard new wings well
that's false advertising because Tamara
snot stood wide receiver now if they got
Emmanuel Sanders yes and they love
Emanuel saying how could you not I know
but that's not happening so to Marius
that would be a great weapon he would be
just another guy that can do a do
everything they want in their offense he
could do all positions the hardest thing
about trades is the PR hit in the
current NFL that teams take from selling
off a player yeah because when you trade
it to Mary s Thomas you look in the
camera and the first question the media
asks is are you rebuilding yeah are you
giving away the season right now the
good thing for Denver is they can go
have you seen Courtland Sutton exactly
saw him again yesterday I mean he's
jumping over people an insistent basis
and catching balls and instead of
getting four we should give him five of
the ones to Marius had it once you drop
to it exactly okay so you could see the
Patriots going after Demaryius Thomas I
definitely could I wouldn't be shocked
if they tried to go for Elwes middle
linebacker - they're saying Brandon
Marshalls on the the trade block
possibly I think that's another thing
that the brown Patriots need we know
that the Patriots love to trade for a
linebacker a deadly right and I think
God no fan noise right stock him up
right like and you know how we talked
about you know I guess it was last week
maybe it was the week before how their
defense is different when I landed
Roberts is in the middle because he's
really one of their true exactly middle
linebackers and I think knowing New
England they have to look at that and
then also looking at their conference
and going hmm gosh Kansas City's in our
conference beat all these things coming
out of the backfield we might have to
deal with the Chargers doing the same
type of thing you got deshaun Watson who
can stress things in the run game and as
you said before if you get a middle
linebacker you can move Hightower to
pass rusher yep which is where edge
center outside linebackers hybrid
linebacker the Saints went out in the
draft and
you traded up to get Davenport right
again every single week this is what I
said about Davenport he his rate of
growth is going to be absurd because
he's so wrong yeah and now cam Jordans
starting to get single covers yeah right
right it's pretty nice yeah
other teams though they're gonna fight
for a pass rusher right now the Rams
apparently looking for a pass rusher
according to Glaser the Packers looking
for a pass rusher ya the Packers need it
I just don't know what pass rusher is
out there unless you're going for you
know the former Patriot right and now
Arizona Cardinal Chandler Jones I don't
know if he's almost like Collins sounds
like that's the possibility out of
Cleveland again you know does Buffalo
become a seller after tonight of Jerry
Hughes exactly right those are the those
are the that's where my you know Shane
ray with the Denver Broncos
he's always hurt right but he's you know
they've realized okay we got Vaughn
Chubb and that's we're good with Vaughn
Chow right so I look at that and go okay
there's another team you know to the
Tennessee Titans do they want to get rid
of an Iraq Poe or Derek Morgan and you
know that those are the things excuse me
that I would look at if you're a team
looking for the pass Russian and then
you know your Eagles you know I went on
the like you know I oh go in the rsn the
regional sports networks there and I
always do the stuff with the Philly guys
which is like one of my favorite hits
nice but shout out to Michael barking
yeah he's the man and they that's the
one thing they asked me if there was a
position you could trade forward with
your Eagles team I mean I don't care if
it's a running back or a receiver but
you need a playmaker it can't just be
Carson Wentz throwing darts to covered
people 40 yards on that no it's just al
Sean and Zach Ertz beasting people
exactly a speed you need somebody that's
gonna stretch it out or just take the
pressure off the offense every now and
then to go oh here's a 60 yard touchdown
okay there's any chance the Cardinals
will get rid of David Johnson I don't
think they just gave him a new do ya I
don't think so I think that's the one I
mean he's in the prime of his career I'm
gonna if I I made a list of guys I'd
like Howie to target I mean I I would
trade for levy on bail mm-hmm because I
feel like I'd like to see him in that
office he'll be amazing other guys that
are more realistic LeSean McCoy Spencer
way
Mike Davis from Seattle right just a
power back yeah
wide receivers DeSean Jackson's my
number one schoiar the Eagles uh
Devante Parker after what I saw I'd like
Larry Fitzgerald what do you well I was
just saying what's screwing the Devante
Parker thing like that would be another
team I would look forward to but the
fact that stills and Albert Wilson got
hurt I bet you that's gonna make them
retract there's Adam GaSe explain not
playing Devante Parker and like putting
it all on him and then the first game at
Devante Parker plays is not only over a
hundred yards but making plays that are
worthy of top 15 wide receiver
consideration it's just coaches get too
caught up and stupid crap sometimes Oh
he's not practicing enough or he messed
up that one assignment on but how do I
not retroactively Lee look at his
decision to get rid of and dama can sue
and Jarvis Landry and wonder if it was
the same ego yeah I think I get that I
also like Devante Parker's performance
made me question everything Adam GaSe
has told me for the last two years yeah
I think that's I'm listen that's a legit
question I also think with the Jarvis
Landry thing he wasn't gonna pay that
amount of money you know I think that's
the biggest thing so it was just a
business decision Parker look I know
Parker's a stud I mean he really is he
is a number one wide receiver in the NFL
if he could stay healthy yeah and yeah I
just think with with at least the other
two situations sue with all the money he
was making he's not worth what he was
making in Miami anymore at this point of
his career okay I think even the Rams
probably overpaid for him to a degree
but they were willing and they're in the
window and then yeah Jarvis Landry I
mean again there wasn't like a huge
market for Jarvis Landry out there we
know that and the Browns took him in not
only just cuz he's a good receiver I'm
not gonna say he's great he's good
receiver but it was also his toughness
and the other things that he can bring
into the locker room because I know that
you're such a fan of nepotism yes Adam
Schefter just tweeted with Greg Williams
taking over as Browns head coach some
are on the league are expecting his son
Blake Williams named new DC oh yeah I
wouldn't shock me get excited yeah I do
like Freddie kitchens at OC
who is he he's
he was in Arizona with Bruce Arians
before this he's so he's gonna be that
style of offense right which which isn't
far from the Todd Haley offense
altogether is it possible to be a coach
under a guy like Bruce Arians and really
capture what he brings because I've
always thought with Bruce Arians offense
it's the the sheer fortitude that he has
yeah I call a play when you're not
expecting yeah like like a lot of people
can call a fake punt but Seattle's gonna
call a fake punt from their one and like
I just making a safety and he just
decided to run he just saw the yes he
did I mean good thing he made it you
know I know the Pete was happy but yeah
that was supposed to be a safety because
they didn't want to be backed up and
give Detroit but that's my thing with
Ariens is like Jerry ins would call
Ariens we always would talk about he'd
be like its second down or ups 14 let's
go for the kill shot like Ariens was
kill shot guy always Oh probably too
much Jeff Courtney's definitely 2 months
but I do think you lost him in that
Cardinals Packers game almost yeah
you're right I did catch cost he's a
unique a unique outlook on offensive
aggressiveness and drawing up plays to
be aggressive to push the ball down the
field and I think that's the best thing
that Bruce Arians brings and that's
probably what you'll see a little bit
with Freddie kitchens the other thing
that our guy Glazer reported teams were
calling about Odell Beckham and I went
all right well I would hope you'd call
about Odell Beckham sure frankly every
team in the NFL if you're not calling
about Odell Beckham you're not doing
your job
Schefter on SportsCenter this morning
said everyone on the Giants is available
except for one player fake one Barkley
sake one Barkley yeah Olivier Vernon is
available that was another thing Matt
was gonna get to in the pass rush thing
like Olivier Vernon after Olivia he was
returning that fumble yesterday I don't
know if I would trade for a living I
think Olivier he's a really good
football player he's never gonna be a 12
Saeki here I always just say he looked
like he was super hobbled yeah I thought
like he just didn't look healthy yeah I
mean I think he's been dealing with this
yeah it's it's now gone high ankle
sprains for that position as you're
seeing with Khalil Mack it's very tough
to overcome I mean you're a big human
being as it is you're
game is on power and then you have to
push a 320 pounder for a living and
that's hard to ever heal right when you
just don't have a huge extended period
of time to kind of just let that process
go about gotcha
but you see Olivier Vernon still as an
eighth sack yeah really good in the run
game yes
disruptive as hell I do I think he's
that I mean the Giants would never trade
within the division I wouldn't think so
okay I mean I would have a hard time
believing that have a hard time thinking
they'd trade with the Packers uh yeah
they might they might do that mmm but
Odell hmm not one of the guys apparently
that's off the books his contract is big
yep I mean they just what do you think
it's going to have to be something like
what's the trade package to first
rounders to first rounders and probably
something else I mean realistically and
then maybe you get yeah I mean that's
gonna have it's gonna that's gonna have
to be something along those lines do you
think someone would have the unmitigated
gall to offer that just looking at the
teams right now do you know something
no I don't I promise you I mean the only
team that would jump out to me like if
we're just talking playoff caliber
football teams that are in the mix right
now right I would look at the AFC and
let's just take the top six the Chiefs
the Patriots the Steelers the techs and
all Patriots maybe and that Texans
losing will fuller exactly that would
suck sucks by the way everybody that was
crapping on me after the Texan started
oh and three is making them my Super
Bowl pick booth but yeah I think that
would be a team I would look at Houston
okay yes New England I don't know if
they'd want to deal with that I don't I
can't imagine it'll be amazing it would
be amazing
I mean it really would be I would but
those are the teams at least that jump
out to me from that standpoint you stood
in New England yeah just in the in the
actual playoff race and then up in the
end the and
NFC oh I'm a little smile well no I mean
it's not the Rams the Saints they're not
gonna do that I don't think you know I
don't think the Redskins are gonna do
that they need that position what about
Carolina yeah
no they don't that would DJ Moore and
Samuel and Funchess I mean we're gonna
get to that Carolina's got it rolling a
little bit and then you know after that
it goes down to your Philadelphia Eagles
once again and that ain't happening no I
mean unless Green Bay decides they want
to do something along those lines but I
would just be shocked that's not really
in their DNA structure to make moves
like that that would be incredible to
Green Bay Aaron Rodgers Oh God the real
Odell Roger I think I would officially
become a Green Bay fan by the way
fantasy team I think we're like a
four-game winning streak Oh baby who did
we beat this week what scrub did we
Kingma the floor with in the Sims and
left go fantasy you don't mess with Sims
and left go in our own league and
vendrick team Odell Rogers beat by
nearly 13 points pigeon-toed freaks
pigeon-toed freaks they're very athletic
yes
but unable to get it done drew clay
board shout at the drew Claiborne drew
Claiborne will fall to 4 & 4 team Odell
Rogers will advance to 5 & 3 a.m. move
in toll-free huge performance by the
Mensch to wreak Colin yeah dimension
what what pigeon-toed athletes are you
thinking about I was I just was you know
watching juju and DeAndre Hopkins and of
course I was just watching a little
Green Bay Rams and Rogers is pigeon-toed
and then I started looking at duck toed
guys - what's like duck toed look out
yeah out right like Jalen Ramsey and
gyre Alexander those kind of guys which
was also funny but I don't even know
what my point was I was just saying that
was funny that we brought up so the
biggest thing I think from yesterday was
Todd Girly's decision in that Packers
Rams game to stop short and to not go in
for that that's amazing so that's the
biggest thing that just tells you what's
wrong with the whole football you know
right there that's the biggest thing it
is yeah millions of dollars
supid ass-kick return by ty Montgomery
no we're gonna talk about Todd Gurley
yeah the game's 2927 yeah man Cooper
he's gonna score touchdown he's gonna
ruin my vantage point and now they're
only up eight well the line came down to
seven and a half worth of line they're
trying to win the game so yeah okay so
now we really think Rogers was gonna
score two possessions no what's that you
really if they miss the extra point
it's gonna be an eight point game and
it's gonna be a one possession game
what do you saying all the people out
there that lost millions of dollars on
this can I say great job on everybody
taking Green Bay to cover yeah ha that's
the funniest thing about this is
everyone's calling it a crying shame
I bet the Packers and I was against Todd
Gurley in fantasy so everyone that's
like Gooch is awful I was like it's I'm
on the other side of the bet come on
like come on what was well my only
question for you in terms of betting
before we get to the film yeah is were
you ever aware of the line as an NFL
player Gurley came out after the game
and said screw Vegas screw the line
screw fantasy but was there ever a time
truly that the players were aware of the
line no hey guys were actually favored
by six I would say the only time and and
I don't even have a specific incident
like just would be you would hear about
the line as a player would be if you're
a huge underdog or a huge fan the coach
would say it like nobody's giving you a
chance you're 12 point underdog and he
might say that on Thursday nobody thinks
we're gonna win so let's let you know
let's play hard let it all hang out wah
wah and I remember the time the Eagles
were 21 point favorites over the upstart
Texans and they would ask the players
you know you're like the largest
favorite ever so only the extremes it's
when it's brought up yes you're never
talking about you know we're a two and a
half point favorite ever come over to
right now serious and you know me like
never a fans never yelled down to you
guys hey I need one more field goal no
no I mean maybe they did but I wouldn't
even do
listen to that or even give that kaiju
think it's gonna be interesting because
todd gurley made a conscious decision to
not score there right and the reason
people are freaking out is even though
ty Montgomery completely put his team in
an awful position when against protocol
completely seceded from everything and
fumbled the ball and cost them the game
yeah we're looking at Todd Gurley
because fumbles are the cause of another
person's action Todd Gurley made a
conscious decision the robot stopped
running yeah I don't want to run anymore
yeah and it just makes me think we have
a team going to Vegas in a few years
there will be a lot of people thinking
about the bets right there right there
will be a lot of people in the stands
that really aren't rooting for either
team they're rooting for the line it
just you know it's those are the plays
where I go they're gonna have to
investigate betting is out of hand I
don't really know what to say it's out
of hand it's all people care about so I
mean I'm gonna be one of the richest
guys in America in a few years cuz all
you other fools are gonna lose your
money betting on this crap man it's just
unbelievable I had a brother-in-law
you're just
deirdre husband yeah I'm a man yeah he's
leaning great dude you know Brian but
damn he bets on more crap and I just
want to go I mean you're sitting on Wall
Street all week and now you're gonna be
an expert on Saturday and tell me who's
gonna win 12 college football games like
get the hell out of here have you
watched a lot of TCU this year right
like and then some of the games he bets
on I want to be like what are you doing
yeah I wanted you know what I want to do
an unscripted PSA yeah for everyone out
there that has watched us to our betting
show and as watch left COEs locks and
guaranteed to lose if the message that
you took away from all of that was that
seems easy I'm going to try you've
missed the message so much of our
message is this is insane I can't
believe people do this every Sunday yeah
it's insane yeah college football makes
more sense than the NFL because there's
a wider talent gasps exactly WNBA and
women's college basketball is actually
the best sports to bet because they're
the most reliable
the NFL is insane don't bet it no but if
you want to bet with us be my guest yeah
go ahead what else going on uh Palace ad
and Instagram DM Dustin said wasn't long
ago that Sims was saying that you don't
coach what Gurley did going down short
of scoring to seal the deal for the Rams
Sunday wonder how he feels about seeing
someone do it anyway yeah I don't what
do you mean you don't coach it oh he's
just he's just saying yeah it's not
something I think that after you know
your man Westbrook and it's happened a
few times why you got more news Thank
You coach yeah I mean I think that's
something that players are aware of in
the situation there and I'm not so sure
that something like that might have not
been said to him on that Latin before
that last dry watching you know ends
that in that way like hey if you break
open here just go down we don't even
want to mess with Aaron Rodgers don't
give him the ball back so I have a
reason why maybe the Patriots are
looking for a wide receiver yeah Josh
Gordon is gonna miss about a quarter of
tonight's game due to tardiness oh my
gosh so we're well can't say oh my gosh
because like we knew this was gonna
happen well that's what we were just
saying can you really depend on not just
the health I mean when I said that
comment I was true leader like you can't
tell me Bill Belichick sitting um
I trust Josh Gordon I've known him for
four weeks and forget the last nine
years I trust them yeah it's how Josh
Gordon responds to missing a quarter
discipline he's a sucky to savant or I
don't know you're here on know well I
know this like I don't know if he really
loves football but he's just naturally
awesome at it
and he has good instincts but I don't
know if he really loves and cares about
it that's the issue with Josh Gordon and
that's why I think people in Cleveland
question them and all of that I think
that's the biggest thing there there's
you really love it is he all in yeah
he'll listen to Tom Brady and he knows
how to learn the offense in a hurry and
all that but as he invested in it all
the time that's got a scare the New
England Patriots really worried about
that 14 points right now but you guys
already know what what's the what does
the injury report right now Gronk okay I
never know what the Patriots and
reporte lie all right Packers Rams yes
so which side of the ball did you focus
on uh the the matchup of the day which
was the Rams offense versus the Packers
defense what we saw in that game yeah in
the first half we saw the Rams get
stymied yes we saw Jared golf under
pressure
we saw Todd Gurley really ineffective in
the first yeah right we saw a few open
completions but in that first half Mike
Patton found something yes he did you
have watched the film
yes Sims right what did they do okay
well a lot of different looks I mean it
was a great game plan by Mike Patton I
think the thing I liked about it
especially early on you know they did
some things like this left go where
they're playing nickel defense and they
put Clay Matthews in Blake Martinez a
middle linebacker and put Mike Daniels
at defensive end and had Lowry 94 as a d
tackle next to Kenny Clark and then
played Nick period at the other defense
in that was a nice little changeup on
the front there you knowing that they
probably haven't seen I know and I don't
think Green Bay's really ever lined up
with that alignment all year long to
really have three defensive tackles play
a four down front to go we're gonna play
nickel so we have a lot of cover guys
but we're gonna be big up front so you
can't just smash Todd Gurley up in our
face isn't this what you say every team
yes it's what the Rams do it's that's
what's the funniest thing I know the
Rams against the Rams right so you out
Rams the Rams
in the Rams yes so I did think that was
cool I think the the other thing is some
cool combination combination coverages I
think the first thing we have to do is
give a ton of respect to 20 and 23 on
the Green Bay Packers
Kevin King at corner and gyre Alexander
I'm not going to overstate this he had
one of the best games at corner out of
anybody I've watched this whole gear in
any game it was that good his job
man-to-man against woods and Brandon
cooks when he had to play the man and he
played a man a lot was off the
charts I mean off-the-charts he is
totally back to healthy dealt with some
growing issues early in the year and you
could exceed the explosion and the
quickness
it's got great aggressive nature at the
line of scrimmage too so I think that's
the first thing you got to look at and
just go WOW goes to to the great job
their game changers on the outside out
of that I just wanted to say this too
they didn't start Josh Jackson didn't
really play you know why why didn't Joe
Jackson play cuz he wouldn't be able to
keep up with exactly right can play
man-to-man so they said the hell with it
but a year which is what does that make
you think going forward well I mean you
know I loved him in the draft I mean I
liked him and Mike Hughes better than I
did Denzel Ward yeah so I mean they
should I your Island they have something
special there yes I can promise you
Brandon cooks is gonna go after that
game going like damn that I haven't
anybody cover me like that all year long
I'm gonna see if I can find a quote yeah
and so Kevin King was good too Kevin
king was extremely good and healthy too
and yes he's a longer type player even
for a longer corner he's got tremendous
change of direction skills but though so
what they did in that that instance a
lot of the times too is they would play
them man-to-man on the outside receivers
they would play Jermaine Whitehead who's
a kid from Auburn he's a second-year kid
who can't have been in and out of the
lineup a little bit they'd let him play
man-to-man on the tight end and then
they would they would sometimes rush
three or rush for you had two free
safety deep but they would have three or
four guys in the middle then to play the
crossers or Gurley out of the backfield
so you got like three man-to-man
matchups with three or four guys just
sitting underneath going oh here this
guy's coming across let's read let's
read Goff sighs and it flustered off I
mean I mean Goff was like well I don't
know what the hell defense was and he
should have been cuz it was a different
look and it was very creative and how
they did it so I think that was the
first thing the changing up looks some
obvious passing situations they put
seven people the line of scrimmage you
didn't know who was coming or who was
going that messed up the protection a
few of the times where you saw Jared
Goff kind of like in the pocket people
all around him and I throw it away or
take hits go ahead you want to ask
question yeah my question was yeah
Denver slow down Patrick mahomes by not
letting
know who was coming in disguising cops
Yeah right the Patriots slow down
Patrick mahomes by pretending to blitz
and not showing who's coming right the
Packers had success in the first half
disguising and not letting you know
what's coming yeah two questions yes why
doesn't every team do that in every game
right I think I think the first those
just answer that you remember your
question it's great you just can't keep
doing it and that's my second question
right why doesn't that work in the
second half because the coach will start
to realize look Dan you want to put
seven people at the line of scrimmage
I'll just start to spread people out and
now you're blitzing guy that's faking
the Blitz and the B gap he's supposed to
get out and cover the slot receiver to
drop it a zone
oh well I'll just tell Robert woods to
hook up seven yards and we'll throw to
him and your guy can't get there enough
and also now he catches the ball it
turns up the field for five or ten more
your Kansas City and the Rams can both
spread you out and go I don't really
care how many people are there exactly
see if you can get over let's see if you
can get over there quick enough exactly
right they put they put you know Clay
Matthews with my comfortable Chiefs and
the Rams do that in the first half why
did the Chiefs and the Chiefs what are
you so against the Broncos and Patriots
and the Rams against the Packers just
figure that out right away yeah I think
it's just it's more about getting a feel
for the game when they're calling these
type of plays have your own gameplay yes
you're trying to make that work and
you're going okay and they're tinkling
tinkering with the formula to go OK and
also the one thing McVeigh does is he
stays patient when the run but in the
third quarter he finally said screw the
run I'm gonna just start to spread you
out and I'm gonna put Todd Gurley you
know we saw the start of it after the
safety rate but Todd Gurley in the slot
Todd Gurley ran the wheel route and
caught the bobbling catch that means
election right and he got manned up on
Jermaine white Jermaine white head there
but then that filter over to the second
half and you saw the big touchdown catch
he had on the shallow cross right there
trying to man up and pass off crossers
he's all the way out on the outside of
the two receivers to the left and
there's three receivers to the right all
three receivers to the right ran across
the field just like pretty much a comb
over the Dinos like everybody holding
everybody here he comes here he comes
underneath and somebody's got to pull
off there I think in the Green Bay like
Oren Burks whose man
man on todd gurley there's no way that I
think Mike Pettine can go oh you expect
Oren Burks to cover him across I do
think it was maybe Germain Whitehead
that was supposed to fall off the tight
end and then take a tog early in that
for instance but it didn't try the case
Jer whatever exactly right it was the
first time they had done that play like
that so I feel right now that if my team
was facing any other team in the NFL
yeah the two people that I would feel
the most helpless against are Tyreke L
and Todd Gurley yeah that when those
guys have the ball you're going I'll
give up 60 just don't give up 70 in a
touchdown right maybe we'll stop Mike
the Packers had like two goal line
stands on girl and I'm like they got to
be going nuts and that was was that
before the safety that was after the
safety when they got the goal line
stands yes because then they scored yeah
when that Rams offense started going
when cooks touch the ball I go okay
that's 25 yards yeah you know when when
wood touches the ball I go okay that's
15 20 yards yeah when Gurley touches the
ball I go yeah it's scary man I know
it's he's he's an MVP I mean that's how
good he is and I think the first thing
I'll look out for the Packers and I
didn't get to watch the Packers offense
first but the biggest thing for me would
be this and this goes for the Rams and
the Chiefs in this conversation when
you're out playing them and you go into
halftime at 10:00 to 8:00 you have
stopped on their throat exactly right
how many opportunities did you have the
ball a 10 to 0 and it's state attendez
here then they get to safety and then
golf escapes it makes the great throw
down the silent it cooks makes that
amazing catch they call it out of bounds
the very next play was the wheel route
too girly okay there's that Oh 10 to 8
okay blah blah blah they put three
quarter starts and they're still doing a
good job they're stopping the run
they're still making things hard on the
Rams and Dan that was the same thing
with Denver Kansas City and then it's 13
to 8 are you ok yeah so doused 13 8 and
the third quarter the same thing you're
gone Dan
I mean they're they're holding their own
on defense but it's not gonna hold firm
no it's not and then in games like that
against the Chiefs and the Rams when you
dominate and you're only up two scores
damn
you know they're an NBA team it's only a
matter of time before they make their
run in the fourth quarter or in the end
of the third quarter
that Rams run to their two touchdowns in
the third quarter to go ten right I was
like packs dead yeah I know and then
Rodgers did Rogers Rogers did Roger
Rodgers like where's Sam Shields okay
let's go pick on him yeah right or and
then the other kid DJ read with Valdez
scalding he beats him off the line of
scrimmage number 32 runs right by him
touchdown now that was another issue as
the well the Packers defense got worn
down I mean really think about it from
the end of the third quarter into the
fourth quarter the Rams had the ball
missed the hole the rest of the game
other than like the five plays that
green beige is someone xìng xìng xìng
touch a weird way the Packers wide
receivers should have pulled a girli yes
I sat down at the ten right oh we need
to give our defense he throws what the
big pass down in the middle of Monta
Adams the very next play is Jones up the
middle for a touchdown it's like I don't
even know I looked at me it's funny man
the Chiefs and the Rams it's almost
better to give them a short field let
them score quickly so that you can take
more time yeah I mean it's there's
something to that you're gonna have to
find that right formula there I'll take
this I know it's like Falcons 2050 yeah
exactly right or 2016 yeah yes
but yes so that was uh that was the big
thing but like I said McVeigh in the
third quarter said to hell with the run
game spread him out golf made some great
throws in the third and fourth quarter I
mean I'm not gonna had to give him a
grade what would you give for the whole
game or the whole game I would say would
probably be like uh just a B but it was
a gritty B because it wasn't easy and
I'm not gonna you know I know everybody
thinks I like to hate on Jared Goff I
don't I he's he's done some things this
year where I like well like we've said
he's gone outside the oh this is just a
great scheme play and I can hit the open
receiver and he showed that on that
drive to get the touchdown to make it 10
to 8 right that was a great back escaped
the pocket through a back shoulder
Cook's makes the amazing throw right
wasn't a great throw too girly the ball
got tipped but he caught it but
nonetheless he meant another a number of
other good tight throws that I said Ben
I mean that was that was big-time but
you know what happens to is the
trickle-down effect I mean once he
spreads you out McVeigh you know
okay you like the Kevin king and gyre
Alexander matchups
and then you start to go then there's
you know you know I mean really we're
gonna trust Jermaine Williams on whoever
he's got to cover the Reynolds kid and
they just have so many different
matchups for Curtis and play for Cubs
not even there there's two Gerald
Everett like you talked about and it
just goes one it goes down the line the
way you beat the Rams what you learned
is disguise but be smart yep have a lot
of cover guys yeah and if you're given a
lead pound you got a pound you got it
that's where the Packers are not good
they can't pound they can't dominate the
line of scrimmage and run the ball when
they need to you know and even you know
Aaron Jones they finally made him the
featured back right everyone's asking
for right and he actually played pretty
well he did but it's not a consistency
in the running attack you know what I
mean it was like 2 6 right 25 right
exactly right - right and that's
different than Gurley who's 6 8 oh well
23 6 4 yeah you know what I mean but do
I look like Jared Goff or the helmet you
guys have that similar I yes you
definitely do and the other thing that
they did - a little bit the Rams they
went up tempo a little bit as the end of
the third and fourth quarter started and
that calmed down when you go up tempo
it's hard to be real creative and go
crazy at the line of scrimmage with
seven people because oh gosh hey we're
in we're in double dog Duty double dog
they know people are like what the [ __ ]
you talking about girlies are oh yeah
and then all said you screw up a play or
somebody screws up the blitz or they
blow coverage so you just I've always
thought that I would show one defense
and then at 15 seconds left when golf
starts changing I would just switch the
defense completely because because if
Sean McVeigh is gonna sit there and tell
him exactly what to do yeah well then
I'm gonna have him tell me what to do
about against a 4-3 base you you need to
have a few of those in your pocket and
do it every time yeah if you do it
enough yeah you do you gotta have a few
of those in your pocket to go oh damn
we're taking a chance on this play
Derrick Brooks used to get us out of
that crap and be like oh gosh they knew
we're bringing four week blitz
get out of this let's go
Tampa 2 or blah blah blah you know what
I'm realizing yeah there's no great
defense this year to battle these great
offenses not really
it's about playmakers on defense this
year the number one defense of the NFL
this year Baltimore led up 36 points to
the Panthers we're gonna get to that a
second yeah the four games before that
they allowed 36 points there is no
Jacksonville this year no there's no
dominant force with a ton of personnel
that you can go they match up well right
him nobody matches up well with these
offenses no well I think it really comes
down to like what the Rams have on
defense okay yeah they've let up some
big plays but you know when they were
down twenty seven to 26 and it was a
third and six you know what happened
Aaron Donaldson exactly right and then
you go damn I mean there was the Packers
chance again to extend to drive and you
got the lead by one and if you go down
and kick a field goal you're gonna score
that make the Rams have to score a
touchdown to beat you
yeah but they got playmakers and that's
what happened and that's one of my
issues with the Packers in general like
can anybody on that team make apply
other than 12 I've talked about the
defense - when's the last time we saw
somebody in the Packers have a strip
sack fumble or a pick six or something
like that I I'm I'm not even trying to
be a jerk right now I'm just trying to
like seriously think as a guy who
watches football as much as I do when I
was just thinking as I'm watching the
game I'm going damn I mean you know
there's just there's no Aaron Donald
bust through the line of scrimmage and
we got a safety there's no Marcus Peters
pick six like we see against the Raiders
game you know who does that on the
package never clay Mathews Kenny Clark
had a good game I know but nobody does
that Josh Jackson did have a pick six
Oh early on yeah yeah okay okay so did
jr. know Jags that was that or that
might have been the preseason that race
you know and I mean so that's what I
mean like there is no running back I
mean Aaron Jones is is better than
Jonathan Williams and Ty Montgomery
right he's not really taking anything
crazy
no not other tight I mean Jimmy Graham
at this point it's not Jimmy Graham New
Orleans it's I haven't Jimmy Graham
Seattle no he's a possession receiver
that's super tall
yes I like fall disappointing I do too
he's got he's definitely got potential I
don't know if that's his name ball does
scalding I believe SCAL
ing here I got it right here if you want
me to look I'm pretty sure I'm oldest
scantling scantling damn he's just got
too many letters
the other s Valdez skin last point here
and I'll get him get on on this game but
this is also what I love about Shawn
McVeigh okay kid genius okay this is
what kid genius does it's third and
seven at the 36 right there down 27 26
left go and the Packers got six guys at
the line of scrimmage double a gap its
third and seven they run the ball up the
middle for 23 yards timeout that doesn't
make sense
yeah that's McVeigh I mean my first
thought is is because it did the two
guys in the a gap drop out they ran like
an inside zone and just mash them in
there and that just tells you the balls
McVeigh has sorry I'll be pretty out
there but yeah he just I'm gonna believe
that my guys gonna execute against this
front and I'm gonna get my guy the best
the best player cuz what he's really
doing is going the games 27 26 we're
losing he's playing for the field goal
so he's really just going hope Todd
Gurley can maybe just give us a few
yards here to make the feel a little a
little easier right but also within that
they execute the right way and he busted
through the middle and gets the 23 yards
you know they end up having to kick the
field goal because they had a holding on
a second down where Gulf scrambled up
the middle but it was holding became
second and 20 and then they ran the ball
two times from there you know so that
just shows you he's got trust in his
defense still even in that situation so
you feel after the game as how much was
what that didn't make any say just feel
after the game is how much yeah I guess
I didn't finish that sentence so you
feel after the game that the Packers
played that best defensive game they've
played all year and they still lost and
the Rams probably were caught off guard
by a defensive game plan that they did
not expect in any capacity and still
scored 29 points that's what's scary
about the Rams right what about the
Packers what about my Super Bowl winning
Packers going forward I don't think so
slugger yeah it's gonna be tough I mean
could they you know I mean hey he's
gonna have to make magic that's all we
can really say
gonna have to be magic up a New England
this week well I mean what else is new
yeah Kenny and McCormick hit us up is it
just me or as Marcus Peters looking like
a liability without to leave uh he's not
a liability I don't think he's been out
of this world this year he's still a
good player but no he's he takes chances
I mean he stares into the backfield too
much what was that they they double
moved him right early on with Davante
Adams wasn't that little stop a go on
him yeah you know that's that's his
career issue but you know with that too
when we get to week 15 or he gets us
some big games he's gonna get one too
and win a game or make a big play at a
game too and you got to take the good
with the bad but that guy still inhaling
says why didn't the Rams run any screens
against the pack yeah that's that that
is something that did jump out to me as
I was watching it especially with all
the people at the line of scrimmage I
was shocked that that wasn't more of the
game plan and I got a think with that
there was something that McVeigh didn't
like on film about the matchup all week
or something in the screen game but I
got no answer for you there mmm yeah so
that you just leave code man the Rams
are incredible yeah the Rams are
incredible Rams are incredible that's
that's why you get the tattoos man the
four teams we'd talked talked about our
notch above the rest of football well
two teams that were not in there yeah
Ravens and Panthers yeah Panthers go in
there put up 36 in Carolina on the
Ravens the number one defense heading
into the week so I had mentioned it
earlier about all the mess ups for a
Baltimore yeah the other things though
that I wrote down before you get in your
notes I'm just gonna share some of my no
it's cool yeah cool
I loved the coaching at the end of the
first half for the Panthers phenomenal
when you when it's fourth down and it's
like a 57 yard field goal and there's
seven seconds on the clock and they put
in their backup quarterback and the
Ravens defense just was like I guess
they're kneeling it I guess they don't
want to give Cam Newton negative one
rushing yards drops back wide open Greg
Olson seven yards took two seconds out
of bound easy kick turned it to 24/7
and get the ball after halftime it was
beautiful and now I go man a lot of
credit autocrat Rivera yes other things
I wrote down I wrote down the Panthers
weapons are real Christian McCaffrey
Devin Funchess have always been there in
their cell mm-hmm
DJ Moore and Curtis Samuel are the next
level guys that they haven't had their
in a while yeah they had they had a few
years of Ted getting right was he there
on the championship team yeah the one
that went this rural area so they had
the speed guys it was like him and
Jericho Khatri and all that stuff yeah
but TJ Moore and Curtis Samuel are
different makers they are but the main
guy Greg Olson is back yes he is back I
went and looked and I said I felt like
every time Greg Olson caught the ball it
was for a big thing and I went back and
looked yeah he had four catches
touchdown three were four first downs
yeah what was a touchdown yeah and two
of the first downs one was on fourth
down the one we just talked about I and
two others were on really long third
down desperations right third and tim
has his security black bat blanket
Christian McCaffrey is his explosive
bell cow for real sure he can run the
ball whenever he wants yeah DJ Moore and
Curtis Samuel are reverses but also guys
that if they catch the ball with space
can take it by themselves yeah and they
have the whole offense and the other
thing I wrote down is if Baltimore is
behind they're dead deep trouble if
Baltimore has to play from behind
they're dead yeah if they can get a lead
Oh
Flacco is comfortable but as soon as
they have to throw the ball with Flacco
they're dead yeah it's I don't yeah I
think you're spot-on with everything you
said there was there anything in the
film of watching the Panthers offense
that made you feel a certain type of way
any big takeaways yeah I think the you
know a little bit like with 12 and 10 or
difference makers like you talked about
it McCaffrey funches they've been there
Olsen's been there but they have a nice
little formula on the offense on the
offensive side of the ball
I think the first thing starts with this
you gotta credit through their Olaf
offensive line
I really do it's we doubted it
especially with a few injuries and being
banged up and having to kahlil's right
right
and you know the kalila center is good
okay the right side of the line with
Trey Turner and the kid Moton Moton are
good okay and the pleasant surprises of
van rotten at left guard replacing
Norwell right and then Chris Clark at
left tackle have done a great job I mean
for everyone out there isn't Chris Clark
the guy that's been on like seven yes
last year right he's been a career
journeyman I mean there are some times
when career journeyman like for the last
year for the Eagles like Steven was new
ski like came out and was like a solid
rock yeah you're like I guess we're
getting that one good year from this
journey one good year like a relief
pitcher usually you know you get with
certain coaches who can teach little
different techniques that you go oh damn
or they can teach the same technique but
for whatever reason they put it in
different phrases or whatever it is and
it just sticks in your mind better what
it is it is wild and again these are
human beings too and sometimes you just
have one year that's better than the
other one and that's part of it but I
think from the get-go the one thing I
saw right off the bat as they said oh
the first thing that jumped out to me I
said whoo-hoo the Panthers the Panthers
oh lion was not gonna be overpowered in
this game that was evident from the
first try how was your big concern it
was so from the first drive where they
did nothing I at least said hmm really
did a pretty good job of like Baltimore
didn't push them back it was a stalemate
at the line of scrimmage and pass
protection was not an issue and so that
was the first thing that I jumped but
then I started to go damn this offense
was Samuel and more in now you know like
Samuel Moore and McCaffrey they're like
all the same guy in a lot of ways it's
like running back slot receiver outside
receiver I think Moore's a little bit
more true receiver but yeah their
weapons and it's I don't even know what
you would call this Norv Turner offense
that he's got I want to call it like the
college spread power option game I mean
that's really what they are it's like
old school power football but cams in
the shotgun McCaffrey's next
their motion and DJ mourn in the
backfield speed sweeps or McCaffery in
the backfield and he's running a you
know wide flare out in the passing game
but you know just like we talked about
with all good offenses that's the one
thing that I jumps out to me about
Carolina on a weekly basis is they make
you defend the whole field hmm might not
be as pretty as the Rams or those Chiefs
and all that but you still have to
defend it and I think that's what's
really cool more especial I don't know
what to say it he's a special player
he's a wide receiver and a running backs
body would you take DJ Moore or Mike
Williams Chargers wide receiver when 7th
overall yeah versus DJ Moore who went in
the first round yeah DJ mortgage yeah
they took yeah he was like what 22nd
pick my first right I mean you know I
like DJ more coming out on the draft I
like DJ more probably more how about
that yeah it's just my kind of guy you
can do more with him and this day he's a
lob ball he's still really good he's
probably even a little bit more than
that but yeah DJ more can catch the lob
ball too he can do that so I think that
was the great thing Moore is special
like I said running through arm tackles
his body control is off the charts and
I've never seen a guy who can change
like speeds where I go doesn't look like
he's running that fast but no one seems
to catch him I think the other thing in
the game 30-yard pickup well that's the
ball was on the ground the linebackers
like it's mine and DG more went not only
am I gonna get it I'm gonna outrun you
too you're off the screen yeah off the
screen and I think that's another thing
that maybe we've slept on about the
Ravens
that's what evident to team speed
especially the front seven speed I mean
[ __ ] think about what the Bengals did to
the front seven speed is an issue I mean
you know jus daun Suggs on the edge
Mosley is really the only real athlete
they got in the front seven so you know
if you want to play in a box right yes
if you want to play in a box and that's
what guys one of the things I wrote
Carolina didn't beat their head in the
ground ago we're gonna run it we're
gonna run a Baltimore the biggest
[ __ ] we've ever seen on planet Earth
long side to side it was it was side to
side with an occasional up the middle
run to keep them honest so I think that
was the first thing and I thought was a
great game plan by north turner but yeah
lack of speed on the edge was evident
from the Ravens other thing I just
thought about and this is just food for
thought you know hey last week's game in
general did that we're at the Ravens
that was a physical hard football game
why that defense was on the field a
whole lot and we talked about that but
you know the the even the moments of
when the Ravens overpowered Carolina cuz
they are the Ravens and I don't care who
you are they're gonna have moments where
they overpower you just don't matter Cam
Newton yeah cuz he don't give a damn oh
you're in my face [ __ ] you I'm gonna
throw it down the middle oh you're in my
face I don't care off you follow around
guys on right and throw like 30-yard
laser that's where Cam Newton in the MVP
race I mean he's not far out of it he's
people need to stop sleeping on Carolina
and I'm sick of the disrespectful Cam
Newton it actually really is starting to
bother me
it is I mean it's every week they're in
the game and it's and when they lose
it's not Cam's fault I mean we're not we
gonna blame cam for the Washington loss
we're gonna blame cam for the awesome
Atlanta game he had early in the year
but they lost say-so the blatant
disrespect and the Cam Newton effect is
real I mean it really is it's hard to
defend Cam Newton and it's not about
this great passing offense and I know
yours probably sick of hearing me say
this but there's so many things you have
to worry about Cam Newton and one of the
big reasons we say you have to defend
the hole filled with Carolina's offenses
cuz a cam dude great arm his runs you
know oh they want to run it off the
right tackle in the Caffrey okay exactly
exactly
like how can you cover one side where
McCaffrey is gonna run it's gonna take
all of your speed but in the back of
your head going I also need to be ready
to stop on a dime yeah go back to the
other pile on because Cam Newton strides
are like the size of my bomb he's
running as good as he's ever run before
and his scrambling in the pocket is ever
as good as well before I fall on a
fumble but I think that's why a lot of
people question Kim is because of that
play I know don't you know don't think
about Willie fall on a fumble forget
about those other 150 times he's run
over middle line what are their core
Bax would dive into the end zone and get
hit and concussed and people would go to
bad play ya know I know it's crazy and
you know I think the other thing too and
you're a little cocky man people get
really upset yeah and you know there he
is again being like a great role model
and giving wristbands and you know
what's he doing now he's giving the ball
and a band off of his two children to
children but what an [ __ ]
the other thing I'm almost done here I
know this is a long no you're going down
but no thanks man um but it's hard I
think the other thing I take away from
watching the Panthers you know really
closely especially the last few weeks
because they've had a lot of big games
it's hard to hone in on any tendencies
the Panthers have you know me I'm pretty
good at going man the Packers just do
this her the jaguars just throw this or
you know I watch and I start to go I
don't know you've said this every week
you don't exactly know what the staples
of the Panthers offense is it's hard to
get a beat on what they're doing in the
formation what's the routes that are
gonna be Ruud it's very hard and north
turner keeps you off-balance off that
that way and I think that's what's
awesome
and then you add into the fact like we
talked about their weapons right which I
wish they would give like they got to
get Jarius right out of there I'm sorry
Jarius you're a good player but you're
not Curtis Samuel or
DJ more anymore the other thing that's
interesting about them is they're three
Ted n set it's another thing like the
kid Ian Thomas is good Imus right high
draft so you know you got him and Greg
Olson and then the other kid Kristin man
hurts I don't know if I'm saying his
name the right way but he's a viable
option so they can get in that personnel
set and then go we're gonna smash
Matthew or they spread out and do like
the old doing one thing so that's just
another thing with them that is very
special and I think the last thing I'll
take away from this game and more than
anything to is you can't really play
Carolina man-to-man that's the last
thing that's gonna be really tough on
teams
you can't play them but Baltimore didn't
even try to mess with them play men are
you talked about cuz one time Greg Olson
was being card man-to-man he just like
destroyed him well it took the inside
also and you just got to think about all
the movement right okay we got to worry
about the pulling guard play with
McCaffrey but also we got to worry about
the bootleg that Olson might come out
the edge and then as they're doing that
power run ply to McCaffrey
there goes DJ more behind you know Cam
Newton are they gonna throw it and then
you're gonna choose one go man-to-man
right and you're gonna be crossed all
over and that's when people mess up run
fits and all that so that's where they
put you in a bind and that again goes
back to the Cam Newton effect because of
what he can do at that position and then
you're hamstrung to play zone and if
your open and Cam's gonna hit you and I
just think that and I think everybody's
sleeping on the Carolina Panthers they
are I think as I look at it I know you
would take probably the Chargers as the
fifth best team I think think I would I
think I would go Carolina fifth and then
maybe the charger six I've added you my
power rankings right and we know the big
four actually I would take the Eagles
fifth they're in there right there would
you really no no okay
yes did you bet on member the Jaguars
yesterday it was push bad it was a mush
bet I had an Eagles win Jacksonville
cover just so that I just think you
juice I think of all the plays lat all
the bets last year where we had against
each other and you just go I took carson
once you took blake bortles i know
that's what i think about you're the one
doing it this year I just get really
afraid betting on all right a few other
little story lines so Fitzpatrick Larry
Fitzgerald excuse me Larry Fitzpatrick
Gerald Larry Fitzgerald caught a
two-point conversion yesterday that
sealed the deal for the Arizona
Cardinals to beat the Niners right and
it was awesome yeah
and afterwards one he ran over a guy
scored a touchdown and then spiked the
ball and I saw this stuff on reddit
about this may be the first time that
Larry Fitzgerald has ever spiked a ball
which is crazy to me but apparently on
the broadcast the local broadcast they
were saying I can't member the last time
Larry Fitzgerald despite the ball he
always just hands the ball to the ref
right apparently after the game Larry
Fitzgerald said I want to apologize to
all the kids that are watching I'm sorry
I set a bad example
get give me a break
Larry you don't have to be the nicest
human ever created in fact he spiked the
ball and his teammates were going nuts
and they're jumping on and he's having a
great time I bet you Larry went home and
he poured himself a little glass of
something and he smoked a cigarette and
he coughed like so much and he was just
like I'm a bad boy
some kasnia could con yack in and a
cigarette cigar he just sitting there
and he's like you know what I like being
bad Larry Fitzgerald spiked a ball and
it's like I spiked the punch yeah I just
think that's hilarious that is hilarious
I agree that was and - oh man Kyle Kyle
but I wasn't even gonna do that I mean
hey listen CJ Beathard is their
quarterback there's nothing really I can
say about it but Ben the ball comes out
of Rosen's hand clean every throw
beautiful spiral minutes what he throws
of where he wants to almost every throw
it's an effortless motion that pops out
of his hand I love that they got David
Johnson involved in the passing game
here we are talking about two really
crappy teams involved in the passing
game and Josh Rosen for me seems more
comfortable with two minutes left in the
fourth quarter than he does with two
minutes left in the first yeah I might
hate this there's something about that
as a quarterback sometimes you'd rather
be in that situation cuz you just go I
can push the envelope speaking of wide
receivers Josh's Adam Thielen now owns
the NFL record for most receptions in
the first eight games of the season 71
he also broke Brooke Randy Moss is
franchise record for receiving yards the
first eight games we're watching
something really special we are and I'll
tell you what yeah
DeLand got that giddyup he does Filan
gets that ball and he goes and take it
hits that that corner yeah it's really
really special it's really good I know I
mean damn I know I haven't what seven or
whatever no Tim everybody looks at me
like with this crap you know because I
everyone's because we Hopkins and Mike
Evans that look awesome this weekend
because Sims people want to say that
because
of Adam feelings numbers right now yes
he's the number one wide receiver with
everybody he's really good I got that I
mean I would I would do anything for the
him to be my receiver III get that he's
amazing I know I'm know it just it
really makes me realize that when people
watch the NFL yes and since they're
either watching red zone or they're
watching one game they look at the
bottom of the screen and they go huh
Devante booker nine carries 87 yards
great day from Devante booker right man
it was all [ __ ] I know it was all
[ __ ] there's a lot of [ __ ] oh oh
look at that oh look at that that Y
receiver Mike Evans 178 receiving yards
right sure I mean 70 it was on one throw
yeah I know I don't know I know I got he
was wide open yeah he's playing
Cincinnati they leave guys wide open
sometimes yeah oh wow
here's my favorite I love the Colts you
know they're one of my favorite watches
and everyone right now is given our man
Chris Ballard a lot of props and
rightfully so four in one year going
we're gonna put Braden Smith at right
tackle we're gonna put Quinton Nelson
their guard we got Ryan Kelly we're
gonna make it all work yeah man Andrew
Luck hasn't been touched in two weeks
they've played the Raiders and the bills
yeah well the bar the rack but I got you
you're right at home now or that they
play the Jets who don't have a pass run
yeah oh wow okay like what do we ever
take in context
I know context has been lost in this day
and age like they played the Raiders
yeah the Cleveland Browns hung up 42 on
the Raiders everybody puts up yards on
the Raiders and doesn't get touched yeah
I mean Andrew Luck was like hey guys I'm
a little bit worried that we're
neglecting Jack Doyle so let me throw
every pass in the fourth quarter to him
don't worry the Raiders won't figure it
out it was like seven slants in a row
two Jack Doyle they were like hey the
radio you know Marlin Mac's got like a
hundred and forty yards I'm a little bit
worried that since naheem hines dropped
that pass against the Jets he's getting
a little bit nervous so let's run it and
get 80 yards rushing with Najee mines
yeah you can do it every year one I love
Quinton Nelson I love Braden Smith I
love
Danzo I love what they got going on
there it's good to see and your luck
back but where's the context I know
nobody gives a damn who the best
offensive are in the NFL okay play the
Raiders every week let's see what
happened yeah I know I know
hey what there's another we got to give
some other people first of all I'm going
to go through all the games really good
let's do that I think we need to carry
your mind well I just was starting off
with the first game of the day yesterday
I mean whence was amazing I just don't
want everybody to know that Talk That
Talk and you were actually a little
impressed with portals bortles had one
of the best halves of football he's ever
had he really did heating the ball on
tight ends hands he ever played a shark
four drops the ball you know and again
the quality of the ball there were
spirals in a few of them things like
that yeah right but talking about wins
but whence was talk about Prince Carson
I mean he was off charts I mean and just
I don't know again you see the respect
Jacksonville had for him after the game
there was a number of black claw as
Campbell hugged him and told him how
awesome he was less camel had this great
clip where Carson Wentz was dust Arnie
ducked underneath him in curtain KS
Campbell went over now his hands on his
head was like yeah that's me that's not
what he would say he go nobody never
done that to me except maybe taller you
go small but once is some of his throws
were off the charts I just hope
everybody realizes what you're seeing
even the you know what we call ackward a
backlash a Dallas a lot of quarterbacks
Jacksonville was running for it
they were like oh here it comes and he
just said yeah I'll throw 95
mile-per-hour heaters touchdown right so
that the touchdown throw to close it out
to Earth's I mean earth was covered I
mean most quarterbacks were to throw a
pick right there he just throw a rifle
right by the guy so that was amazing and
yeah bortles did had a good job in the
in the second half he really did but but
also what came down to the last play of
the game on that fourth down hey this is
my issue with bortles it was three by
one all go with the shallow cross so
they had three go rousing the front side
and the inside guys there to be had but
he doesn't want to throw that because
it's not his comfort zone so it doesn't
have
so that would be my first one the next
game we need to talk about home before
we do that just to address Josh
I do not read things from take artists
in this world there's a number of you
take artists something he sent me
something from a person on Twitter who I
don't even want to give the validation
of reading there now I want to know but
there's a number of people that work at
Fox Sports that I'm not interested in
playing your game it's not a good game
are they coming at you or me personally
no they were caught they were
questioning Carson Wentz as a one-year
wonder that's just stupid [ __ ] exactly
everybody up there just whoever that
person is that said it and I don't know
because they haven't told me and we're
not gonna say their name that's a they
just don't waste your time listening to
them I don't know what else to say you
know when it's fake and you know what
it's real I mean come on all right so I
want to give since we're gonna go back
and forth here giving people praise I'm
gonna give Washington praise they've now
held McCaffrey Zeke and say Quandt under
a hundred yards combined our man say his
name Tehran pain no Jonathan Allen no
the defensive coordinator is what muskie
yes did you not know his name in your
ass no I knew his name I just wanted you
to get there Bregman Husky yes
like all dude than the Saints that's
what we have to do so use this to our
advantage right the rest of the country
is going i watch the washington redskins
allow 7,000 yards and 200 points against
the saints exact Washington's defense
stinks yes
Washington's defense is the real deal
they have everything in Reston Smith
Ryan Kerrigan on the edge right DJ
swearin sure with a little bit of
attitude
right Josh Norman my afraid to come up
and play in your hip hop maybe in Monroe
the Dunbar do you know how is be your
man morovich he's good he's not as good
as I would have hoped he would have been
you know Zack brown in the middle I mean
go sack Browns ledger players and their
coach so well guess they blew three
coverages against the new office never
really puts them in bad situations yeah
and they're just they're a good football
team they need to continue what they're
doing and I know we've said it a lot I
don't think it's sustainable I don't
know if it is either the Giants come
back as the Panthers almost came back we
games
I know discuss like their defense is
going to keep them in it and again they
need to run the football the strength of
their football team is they have two top
ten picks on the left side of their line
and they have a second-round pick at
right tackle than Morgan Moses and they
are a running football team and that's
what they should do power and power and
then you do bootlegs and play action
with Alex minutes because if you're
relying on Alex not the drop back or
pick you apart in the shotgun I promise
you you're not gonna win I would argue
that yesterday they did exactly what you
wanted yes Adrian Peterson had one carry
for 64 yards and a touchdown other than
that yes 25 carries 85 yards yes 3.4
yards a carry destroy I will also say
this yes I know that Eli career is done
and I'm so happy that the Eagles proved
it on that Thursday night yeah but I
will say it's 10 to 3 Olivier Vernon
scoops up a fumble and runs all the way
down to Washington's 39 Giants go for
play 7 yards turnover on downs but on
that 4th and 3 Evan Engram dropped that
ball and if he would have caught that
the Giants could have maybe gone down
scored a touchdown tied it up yeah was
not Eli's fault no that wasn't a bad
drop by but Eli's interception of the
five-yard line was his fault well
whenever going into story put me in the
position to defend Eli don't do it
yes shout out to our man tarik cohen
shout out to tarik oh and the long 70
yard touchdown catch and a 20-plus yard
run that led down to the touchdown to
Anthony Miller the only two touchdowns
of the game yeah tarik oh and surprise
surprise
ever since he hung out with Simms and
left go has had a touchdown in every
game and the Mensch is not on the bench
he's killing it you can smell the stench
you can and he's good ball and he's been
balling he's the number one weapon on
their offense he's there Tyree kill
there's just a little bit more running
back version ish and then Travis Keys
running is a difference it is it's a
really big difference for that football
team you got another shout out for us
yeah I got two more shout outs ok
alright go 1 maybe I said I'm gonna do
one then we'll go both I mean
number three for Seattle yesterday oh
hey listen that run game it's good and
don't get me wrong I love watching that
old school pulling guards but Russell
Wilson some of those throws and plays he
made in that football game
or why I say Russell Wilson's one of the
five best quarterbacks in football are
certainly into that discussion I mean
come on
running around dodging people running to
his left throwing 30 yard touchdowns I
mean yeah there's just there's not a lot
of people in the sport that can do that
him and then that kid more I mean more
is he's a weapon he's taking brandings
crazy crazy I mean he's covered it
doesn't matter Wilson puts it there and
he's something he's gonna come down with
it by the way Seattle yeah is now home
of the left goes worst prediction of the
year Seattle's gonna come out starting
slow
Russell Wilson 1st half 11 of 12 151
yards and three touchdowns yeah I went
back and I wanted to kind of look at
Seattle and kind of figure out their
running game so I went through the NFL
Jesus book right the first two plays of
each first half drive Chris Carson
touched the ball right every time they
started to drive here Chris establish us
establish us I think Chris is a is a
monster and I think he's he's kind of
like a I'm never gonna compare anyone to
young Adrian Peterson but they're using
him in the same way Seattle in the last
four games so since the Dallas game is
averaging 35 point to rush attempts per
game love it they've run it a hundred
and forty-two times in all of the Giants
eight games they've run it a hundred and
forty nine so in four games Seattle's
run it almost as much as the Giants have
in eight games they are the number one
team in Russia temps and they are 32nd
in pass attempts and a lot of people
would say that's wrong for the
modern-day NFL we always talk about
zigging when people Zack are you ready
to tackle Chris Carson 32 times in a
game are you ready to tackle Mike David
Mike Davis but he's healthy but also I
like Russell Wilson off the play action
more than I like Russell Wilson sitting
back there in the pocket read Russell
Wilson off the play action is perfect
also
not a huge fan that carry on Johnson got
eight carries yeah I don't get that
either I don't I don't know and Stafford
threw an interception on the one and
fumbled yes and Ameer Abdullah yeah yeah
that was that was a game-changer I want
to give props to Adam Vinatieri sure
now the all-time leading scorer in the
NFL the main reason I'm very happy about
this and other than the fact that we get
to hang out with Pat McAfee and he
filled us in about how good of a guy he
is Satan Manning that was paid man but I
have never respected and this is gonna
sound awful Morten Andersen and Gary
Andersen those guys were always the guys
they were just the kickers corny
haircuts same last name not related
what's up Morton Anderson's helmet in my
room like it's true helmet cuz like
they've people would trade things at the
Pro Bowl my dad had Morton Anderson's
helmet I don't know why but I had it big
helmet oh he's got a huge head
bobblehead helmet but the thing about
out of it and Terry being the all-time
leading scorer in NFL history there was
never a kick that Morton or Gary had
that I'll never forget
Yeah right Venna terry has the big
moments right he's got the cool story he
did it for a few teams won Super Bowls
with different teams
he has arguably like he definitely has I
think the hardest kick in NFL history
with the snow kick yeah that was that's
the first kick I think of always right
but then I also think about the Super
Bowl kick ice in his veins after Tom
Brady drives them down to beat the Rams
did it to my Philadelphia Eagles did it
to the Carolina Panthers the game-winner
right Venna Terry that came after he
missed his first two field goals of that
game oh yeah that's what's amazing and
great his first name ever yeah by the
way in that Indy Oakland game I looked
it up yeah I went through every team's
record in the fourth quarter and I
wanted to see their fourth-quarter
margins this year yeah
the Oakland Raiders have been outscored
85 to 34 in fourth quarters this season
- 51 who they are the worst in the NFL
in fourth quarter mark
by at least 20 gosh no one's worse than
30 like even the Browns are in like the
- 20 30 Raiders - 51 in the fourth
quarter if you're playing live action
think about it
Rams Raiders came close game falls apart
in the fourth quarter last I mean they
got outscored by like 21 against the
Colts yeah fourth quarter the Raiders
fall apart yeah you want to go through
more those ghosts you want to give
credit oh okay I just wanted to make
sure yeah I mean to see the Chargers
yeah they've been outscored a lot the
fourth quarter you're right I didn't
mean to do it like that the other one I
mean okay I've never seen a guy throw
for 300 yards and four touchdowns and
nobody talked about a less than Patrick
mahomes yesterday I mean that's what
he's already done to us and week eight I
mean that's amazing - well I mean 25 of
that one touchdown was a handoff that we
call a pass but my fantasy teams not
upset
well it's incredible he's incredible
they're incredible Tyree kill caught a
ball got raked over the hill head right
and still almost outran the entire team
I know I was watching a highlight show
us that they're like whoa Chris Harris
called him I wanted to be like well yeah
I mean he was gonna dead stop a dead
stop and then run again after already
going full speed and somebody pulled on
him I mean he's not like Superman
alright so we covered Travis Kelce okay
we got
Tyree kill all right we're gonna
somewhat contain Kareem hunt right whoo
touchdown saving Walker right let's see
that that's the other thing too side a
friend text me last night like it just
seems like everybody's open on you know
it's easy for my home sometimes I mean I
think maybe we're over raiding him and I
want to be like wait friends yeah an
idiot is what he is he's one of my new
jersey friends I wanted to be like well
this is what I tell I said dude they're
open because of Patrick mahomes they're
open because of Tyree kill because the
secondary is 30 yards downfield worried
about mahomes throwing a laser over
their head - Kelsey or Hill and then
there comes Sammy Watkins on a shallow
cross that's the thing that jumps out to
me I mean Sammy Watkins is got to be
like damn I'm I used to be the clear out
guy now I'm getting all the benefits
from the clear out
and I'm catching all these easy ones
over the middle and I'm getting to do
something for the first time in my life
it's got to be extremely refreshing for
him but again like it you know hey great
play design is great play design but
what also is making these people open is
the talent of the guys on the field with
mahomes is big arm and then Reid calling
plays that are aggressive with Hill and
Kelsey going down in the field it just
puts the defense in the unenviable
position to where they go man we can't
cover it all and then there comes Sammy
Watkins on a shallow cross well I'll
just say that not covering that game
kicked me so hard and literally on the
onside kick Josh is in the room now
literally an onside kick I said my only
chance for a real cover is someone on
Kansas City scoops this up and runs for
a touchdown right Anthony Sherman picked
it up so clean and one dude barely got a
hand on his foot he was going 40 yards
for the tie really thought you're gonna
get the touchdown - when they started
laterally at the end
oh my gosh Emmanuel Sanders gonna throw
this ball across the field and
somebody's gonna pick it up and run in
for a touchdown let me tell you they
didn't cover on that what do you have on
that game how much money a hundred yeah
all right so here's a few things about
mahomes mahomes is 26 touchdowns are the
most in the first nine career games
since 1951 more are ready then Alex
Smith had last year as the number one
rated quarterback in football he's on
pace for 52 yeah be the second most in
NFL history 55 he's one of three
quarterbacks with Tennessee side passing
touchdowns in the first eight weeks of
the year Peyton and Brady Peyton and
Brady for the 25 through the first eight
weeks yeah yeah that's that's I always
look at I always think I think Brady's
50 did he throw 50 I was there for
everyone 2007 yeah I was there for that
day in an undefeated year yeah I was
there in in giant stadium for that more
aggressive
I think his was more impressive than
Manning's well no [ __ ] cuz Manning's was
chasing numbers and Brady's just doing
whatever I mean Manning's got many just
got so many bullcrap threw a hundred
right there just all of that and I'm not
saying Brady had like 25 bombs
yeah that's what I mean it was an Randy
Moss wasn't catching screen passes at
the three yard line
and then could go well he had Randy Moss
yeah I get it I know I know that's
that's part of it too but one other
thing I want to say I have two other
things about one about the Kansas City
Chiefs 2-month against issues DeSean
what the Sean Jackson broke Jesse Wow
DeSean Jackson broke Jerry Rice's record
of 60 plus touchdowns yeah it's a good
one Jerry Rice had 23 now DeSean West
Josh Sean Jackson has 24 Shaun Watson I
don't know what I'm doing in a hundred
and forty seven games so I start this
all over cuz you've been a absolute
dumpster fire here say this DeSean
Jackson has 24 touchdowns of 60 or more
yards passing Jerry Rice okay it took
him a hundred and forty seven games got
you he has 24 Tyree kill has 12 in 38
games and he also has like three or four
that are like 58 yeah 57 right that like
don't count right 12 in 38 DeSean has 24
in 147 and I would say that to show him
when he first started with speed that
I've never seen before
yeah I was up there the other thing I
want to say is I think it's time when we
are having our discussions for top five
running backs that Kareem hunt should be
in the discussion yeah and I don't even
think in the discussions enough I think
he deserves a spot because I look at the
other guys and he's ahead of David
Johnson he is he's ahead of levy on bail
I think if Le'Veon Bell even came back
right now I would still take Kareem hunt
over Le'Veon Bell
I would I would take Kareem Hunt and
this is a crazy one over Alvin Kamara
because I look at Kareem hunt and I see
all the versatility and I mean holy crap
I feel like he could jump over him a new
bowl at this point he's a stud you're
not gonna agree with no no I I totally
agree I it's funny you're bringing this
up cuz I thought about the same thing
last night cuz I just went damn I think
the last time I made a top five running
back list I didn't put Kareem hunt and
he's definitely in people bring up
Kareem hunt when you're like seven and
eight yeah
and I think if you bet again I think my
top two were hands down I know my top
girly and Gordon know girly and say Quan
Barclay girly say Quan Gordon I think
I'm gonna go girly say Quan Kareem hunt
Melvin Gordon
I don't know then I might go Ezekiel
Elliott of crab Africa then Melvin
Gordon but I'm gonna put cream out in
front of him album Kamara is right there
fighting for that fifth spot but he
can't do what they do on an every down
base I don't know if they can't do what
he's a really tough one he's very close
into that number five range and I know
people are gonna think I'm just
respecting the Saints once again but you
know yeah I think it's funny you're
bringing this up though I actually was
thinking about this like man I'm not
sure I gotta rethink this running back
position thing I'm not counting levy on
bail at all he's not in the discussion
right now he's not even in the NFL so
when that when he gets into that and
shows me something again so I'm glad
that you agree with my point I think you
don't make a graphic and you're gonna
get all the credit for it when I'm the
one that had the balls to say it typical
last thing I want to say he's such an
[ __ ] last thing I want to say Jaguars
Eagles won this Jordan Matthews return
season is crazy
yeah signed by the Patriots injured
cast-off Eagles fans going we don't want
him anymore comes back I mean he makes
every big play for this team
like every big play is jordan matthews
going over somebody and catching it then
it's like I feel like Billy Madison I I
know thank God we called that guy yeah I
know I mean think about the I don't I
think it was a third down we're like
when's kind of guy pushed out of the
pocket of his right and Matthews was
going to cross the field of those left
and he just still threw a rifle as he's
going out of bounds and he comes up
there and catches it well covered yeah
first of all the balls to throw it and
then the great catch but yeah it's
amazing
yeah if Carson obviously feels very
comfortable throwing me well they're
like best buddies right so the Jaguars
had six plays that required either 1 or
2 yards for a first down they had a
second and 1 a third and 1 a fourth and
1 a second and 2 a third and 2 and 1/4
and 2 this Jaguar is called 0 run plays
that's pretty amazing like bortles went
over five passing on those six downs and
converted the initial fourth and one by
scrambling for four before he got out of
bounds yeah we've talked about this
before and just to go back to Blake
bortles one more time one of his biggest
weaknesses with the old regime before
Nate Hackett and Marrone got there they
couldn't call three-step drop passing
game he was the worst three step drop
passing game quarterback in football
because of the long delivery with
shorter passes you have to be more on
point and be able to get it out of your
hand even quicker not to say that it
always takes like this greater greater
talent but you have to be a hair more
precise to be like I gotta read it real
quick and I gotta get it out and pops
yeah exactly right like Drew Brees you
see him do it he's amazing at it right
and that's not part of his game and
that's yeah that's a shame and like
we've talked about this the last five
weeks there we're good last year because
they got in those situations and they
just bawled you with Leonard fournette
and then they'd get in those situations
you go damn we got to stop Leonard
fournette and then they run the boot and
then you go look at portals see right
now their number one option is the boot
it is yeah yeah all right this is a
really long podcast yeah it seems like
it thought I had a good time I think it
was a good one good good first Sims I
like you peace out homies fur fender ik
the evening and the lef koe man says
good night Patriots please cover thank
you so much